hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast crisper and the offend
mediated gene editing for the
exploration of neural sound mechanisms
and modeling presented by Jeremy Liam
product specialist functional genomics
mill poor Sigma I'm Alexis Carla flats
and I will be our moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
birds and sponsored by milla poor Sigma
for more information about our sponsor
please visit WWE MDM le port comm before
we begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box that appears on the far
left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen
once there's many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom of
center of your screen or use the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the Rastas to obtain your credits
please join me in welcoming Jeremy Liam
I will now turn the presentation over to
him thanks Alexis my name is Sherman
leavened I've been with mill for Sigma
know for almost 10 years most items but
then research and development working
with CF ends perform genome editing
experiments and now most recently
working as a CRISPR product specialist
doing technical consultation guide RNA
design donor design among some other
things here in my current role Miller
for Sigma is the life science business
of Merck KGaA out of Darmstadt Germany
operating here in the US under the name
milk or Sigma
so we have a long history of expertise
of gene editing we've been in the
exclusive supplier of zinc finger
nucleases for research purposes for the
last decade and we're one of the first
companies to commercialize CRISPR
reagents we've received multiple awards
for our innovations and offerings in
this in the CRISPR space and 2015 with
the an award for the CRISPR epigenetic
activator based on dead cast 9 fused
with AP 300 histone acetyl transferase
domain more recently and 2016 an rnd top
100 Award winner for the Sanger arrayed
Limpy Bob Christopher library's down
2017 and 2018 we're coming out with new
libraries for CRISPR based an activation
with the same library so let's jump
right into it when people talk about
using CRISPR or crispy CRISPR mediated
gene editing we're usually talking about
nucleate space creation of
double-stranded breaks in DNA these are
are targeted to specific sequence in
that DNA when using these technologies
the offense or crispers we're relying on
endogenous DNA repair mechanisms to
achieve the desired modification the
outcomes are achieved through either
non-homologous end joining and you see
on the left or homology dependent pair
that you see on the right there are some
tools and strategies that can shift this
balance a little bit but it's not really
your choice which mechanism the cell
uses to repair the double-stranded break
and the most often using is
non-homologous end joining which creates
a which is error-prone it creates a
mutation at the side of the
double-stranded break off in term and in
dell which is a word for a comma but
it's like a combination of where it's an
insertion and deletion so the the
fullest end of Christopher's utility
really extends beyond trying to cutting
them DNA though you can use it as
nucleus independent applications were
using CRISPR as a tool to do as a cargo
delivery method so this is a closer look
at how Z offends and crispers work they
both create targeted double-stranded
breaks and DNA but there are key
differences between the two technologies
z offense are composed of a DNA binding
domain made up of protein that is fused
to another protein the fáák one nucleus
each zinc finger recognizes three base
pairs in this link to you know three or
four or five other zinc fingers to bind
up to 25 different bases of DNA
specifically and these two zinc fingers
come together to cut DNA when in close
proximity as you can imagine them
generating custom DNA binding proteins
for every sequence you want to target
can be quite laborious this is partly
why CRISPR technology has been so
revolutionary the CRISPR system uses
just 20 base pairs of complementary RNA
sequence it's a target DNA before
binding with the trace RNA and
recruiting the separate protein casts 9
the nucleus which comes in and cuts DNA
one of the key requirements for cast 9
is the pam site which you see there in
blue
pam size so it makes any Givens sequence
of DNA eligible for the creation of a CR
RNA and cleavage by cast nut a pam site
is a sequence of DNA a Quantium
dinucleotide or in GG the Tracy RNA
exists to tie the CR RNA the targeting
molecule and cast line together and it
is an invariable sequence of RNA that
can either be connected to the targeting
portion of the RNA or left separately
for delivery and ribonucleoprotein
applications so Chris burg based genome
editing and zfn zoom in against tool can
be used to achieve a wide array
genetic modifications gene knockout is
perhaps the most simplest of
applications shown here and will later
we'll go into more detail on targeting
these first two features as well I think
things like transcriptional activation
are possible as well as fusing a
reporter gene or making specific
sequence changes like you might see in a
disease modeling of a single nucleotide
polymorphism mutation but first we want
to take a moment to talk about how we
might go about fusing a reporter gene
well you see here is an example of some
work we've done internally almost ten
years ago now where we tagged the active
gene with a red fluorescent protein to
do this we designed Xia fens targeting
very close by the start codon for this
gene and integrated a red fluorescent
protein just at the n-terminus we used
homology arms that were 848 basis and
593 bases in length the left and right
side respectively and again integrated
this red fluorescent protein as a fusion
to the coding sequence for the actin
sheet this allows us to visualize that
cytoskeletal element and create some
really nice images via fluorescence
microscopy so you can do more than tags
one gene at a time then you can also tag
a multiple different elements within a
cell in this particular cell line we
tagged the nuclear cytoskeletal element
in with blue fluorescent protein and as
well as tubulin with GFP this creates a
Triple E labeled cell with the all these
different cytoskeletal elements visual
visualized in a fan via fluorescence
microscopy these are actually reporters
of the cytoskeleton all it's a question
not over expression systems as well so
really very interesting for any
experiment that you're trying to do
if I wanted pagan to go over a similar
application where we're using
fluorescent protein and creating a
reporter gene or reporter construct this
is the publication that was done in 2011
using zinc fingers to tag a specific
gene that is expressed in the
development of neural tissue this neural
tissue is named the ad new hypothesis
which is really another term for the
anterior pituitary and the reason that
these researchers want to tag that
tissue so that they can study the
development of that tissue the tissue is
responsible for the production of
glucocorticoid homework hormones things
like thyroid stimulating hormone ACTH as
well as LSH let's take a closer look at
what they did in this specific
application back in 2011 was the offense
the first I'll take a look at the new
gene expression Network that's at play
and during development and the this
particular tissue type they
differentiate it in Brianna Steph cells
into or elected erm which is
characterized for the expression of the
pitx1 gene and px2 gene before they get
to the gene that they tagged in this
experiment the eight which is
responsible for the formation of these
raft keys pouch progenitors and the
anterior interior pituitary tissue limb
three limb three expresses luteinizing
hormone and follicle stimulating hormone
they talked about earlier among some
other glucocorticoid so it's a very
important issue to be able to model and
and study if you're looking at neural
development processes this is an
illustration of the donor constructs
that they use to integrate the flora for
behind the limb three gene when we're
talking about a donor construct we're
talking about a template for homology
directed repair and this application
they used one kilobase homology arms on
the left and right side it's equally
sized we see that
these Hamas rooms can be different in
length they don't have to be exactly the
same but if they're that they are the
same that seems to be an easy way to
move forward with the design of your
donor construct again much like the
cytoskeletal reporter LAN I showed you
earlier they targeted the n-terminus of
this gene to integrate their floor for
so creating a fusion just behind the
start codon and something they did
different in this experiments include a
motive selection on their integration
cassette that mode of selection is
antibiotic resistance cassette which is
flanked by loxp elements so that they
could excise that particular sequence of
DNA leaving behind only the reporter
gene fused which is limb 3 fused to the
Venus fluorescent protein so let's take
a look at some of the data that they
were able to generate in the cultures
that they created to differentiate into
limb 3 expressing tissues are called
large cell aggregates which are cultured
under the conditions containing a sonic
hedgehog agonist molecule so in order to
induce expression of limb 3 they see
this nice increase in expression in
fluorescence such as directly driven off
of that reporter contract that they made
that the figure I hear is a flow
cytometry analysis figure J an image of
these large so aggregates out of low
resolution k start to see even higher
resolution here some of the pouch
formations and that that's extracellular
formation of these rathke's pouch
components and then when you take a
cross-section of those large cell
aggregates you start to look closer you
can see the limb 3 specific cells there
and figure out these are the cells that
are responsible for gain for the
expression of an secretion of those
looka coracoid home hormones
so tagging your reporter gene really
isn't the only thing you can do with
crisper as the offense of course you can
do more simple things like gene knockout
but those can also be used in more
complicated experiments so here we move
on from from fusing reporter Sheen into
Gina I've got application this is a
paper that was published using some of
our reagents 2016 targeting the PCM 1g
PCM one sheet is implicated in in
several different oncology studies as a
marker that might be useful for but
targeting and it's chemotherapeutic
agents PCM one depletion inhibits the
growth this cilia genesis and it
increases cell death and sensitivity to
team is all of mine we take a look at
any gene that we want to study for gene
knockout it's important to understand
the structure within there and in the
architecture of that gene the human PCM
one gene is the rather large and
complicated gene it has approximately
nine kilobases of coding sequence 51
different available transcripts 39
different exons and when you process the
coding sequence for this change this
gene you get 44 different available 3
base pair of mismatched guide rnas so it
makes it difficult to choose which guy
in RNA that you would want to move
forward with for gene knock out some of
the rules that we like to employ when
we're doing these that gene knockout
guide RNA designs with that we target
within the first two-thirds of coding
sequence outside of the first ninety
base pairs i target outside of the first
ninety base pairs to ensure that we
don't run into any issues with
alternative start sites sometimes in
that very beginning a coding sequence
you can have an alternative start site
and then pick up gene expression
after you've induced a mutation in
coding sequence
but again it's early on in the coding
sequence as possible then you also want
to select a guide RNA that targets that
is common to all different transcripts
are so coding sequence among these
different transcripts is often shared
and we want to target coding sequence as
comments for all 51 as you see the here
that some of the data for the guide RNA
them shows them for this experiment that
it targets all 51 different transcripts
it has a high specificity score as well
as a acceptable efficiency score we see
specificity scores are pretty accurate
efficiency scores less so we see
typically guide RNAs with scores above
thirty thirty mark for efficiency have
good activity in cells but there's not a
lot of correlation between guide RNA
activity and the efficiency score
besides that so take a closer look at
some of the data here in this
publication the ll 0 and s 3 are two
different glioblastoma cell lines within
those cell lines two different clones
were made wild-type clones that were
just purified and gone on to the same
genome editing processes but with but
non targeting constructs and then PCM
one containing clones or PCM one to
please Jim constant you see nearby and
we measure that percent of Scilly a ssin
which is implicated in that metastasis
of these cell types we've seen the clone
ash 9 and clone v9 here with a
significant decrease we also see that
these these PCM one knockout clones are
more susceptible to the chemotherapeutic
agent team is all a minor TMZ which is
what you see in the figure on the right
so this experiment was done with plasmid
DNA they actually sorted these
glioblastoma cells based on GFP
expression of a
good containing cast nine GFP the guide
RNA for 14 in the guide RNA for gene
knockout but there are several other
applications with RNA and any flinty
virus leti virus has become as a growing
area of CRISPR Bouvier - gene technic
gene editing and so let's take a look at
another publication most of our products
using lentivirus in the application in
2000 model this application this study
looked at reversal of hypofrontality and
animal models of addiction in
schizophrenia hyper fatality is common
in cell models of addiction and in
animal models of schizophrenia it's
characterized by a reduction in activity
in the prefrontal cortex so let's jump
right into this paper let's take a
closer look at some of the data that
they were able to generate with gene
knockout using lentivirus one of them
briefly state the genome-wide
Association studies that they had
indicated snips and the human CH RNA v
sheet and that's the gene that we're
gonna be targeting with the the guide
RNAs for this experiment this gene
encodes for the a5 nicotine agent
because energy see the cholinergic
receptor subunit and in mutations there
increase the risk for smoking in
schizophrenia prefrontal cortex
spontaneous default activity is altered
in those psychiatric disorders including
schizophrenia and the thought here is
that perhaps nicotine and self
administration of nicotine via heavy
smoking is a way to kind of
self-medicate by some of these patients
who are who are experienced
schizophrenic symptoms
so if you would take a look at some of
the data indicated above hyper
frontality and mice VIP expressing
neurons we have a certain level of
spontaneous activity and then we look at
VIP expressing neurons have been applied
with a guide RNA targeting CH RNA v
which is the scene implicated in
schizophrenia we see that a reduction in
the activity at those VIP expressing
neurons that's the data that you see on
the left then it's really represented as
a decreased level of spontaneous calcium
transients lose NAC and figure II is a
different representation of the same
that same data its population averaged
indicating again a reduction in
spontaneous firing rates and figure F
here at the median firing rate is
reduced in ch RNA v knockout mice so
these and these aren't actually not CH
RNA v knockout mice thisis these are
mice which have had lentivirus injected
into layer 2 3a the prefrontal cortex I
mean when we look at a test a test of
their hypothesis here which is that
perhaps nicotine would have would impact
this and relieve some of those symptoms
of high poverty and you see that cells
and mice that have the alpha 5 snip
modification of CH RNA v or it's
efficiency there have a decrease in
spontaneous activity and VIP expressing
neurons we see that that decrease can be
rescued by through administration of
nicotine the deficit data you see there
on the left of the data on the right
here is a kind of a time course across C
D and E looking at the reversal of
high-profile tality and again the
increase in spontaneous activity at
those neurons
I threw administration of nicotine over
to seven and 14 days so there are
numbered different formats current that
our customer products are available in
plasmas being the most common format but
again also in vitro transcribed RNA
which is suitable from in real
microinjection and the lentivirus like i
just talked about which is good can be
used for screening and difficult to
transpile as well as in vivo injection I
wanted to take a brief moment to talk
about a few new proximate we have coming
out that we're really excited about
these are in protein formats
okay these are delivered in the cells
that have activity immediately can be
used for micro injection or tree
inspection and they are available as
wild-type cast line casting nikkei's
enhanced specificity cast line two
products I want to talk about today are
two that have come out very recently
first one being FM cast line which is a
different species of cast line from
Francis elenova Saida moon the key
characteristics of this version of cast
liner that it creates a sticky sticky
cut at the side of the double-stranded
break as opposed to wild-type cast name
which creates a blunt ended cut there we
also have come up with a new D cast line
protein which is fused with the 3x flag
peptide as well as biotin these have a
couple of different applications so I'll
show you some of the data that we have
coming out these two proteins that have
been out in the last couple months
Francis elenova sided cast line we found
to be particularly useful for direct
cloning of large genomic fragments and
largely because of that's sticky and
that's generated after the
double-stranded break in DNA it doesn't
have the same high level of activity
that wild-type cast line does on cells
but it has actually had a higher
activity and in vitro applications we're
just simply digesting DNA
performing molecular cloning experiments
here we have a look at some of the data
here showing FN cast 9 or NP promoting
more effective cloning a large 12 KP
Zack Z locus as compared to wild-type
SSP cast line cloning here performed in
the coli bacterial strain BL 21 de 3x
some data on our D cast line 3x flag
protein is but particularly useful and
chip assays and should pull down
experiments here we take a look at a few
different markers at the p21 Lucas I'm
looking at a pool of three different
guide RNAs bringing in D cast line to
target in here there and so when we use
different antibodies flag antibody
biotin cast 9 as well as a p53 antibody
ditch which was actually what we use to
label the tracer RNA we've seen that
these chips show specific enrichment of
all those different antibodies on the
p21 promoter just like p53 over non
specific antibodies and fold enrichment
here is calculated as specifically
antibody over mile sighs you see
nonspecific and then another
representation of the same data we were
looking at percent input chips again
here show specific enrichment a flag
biotin gas line and is on the p21
promoters similar to p53 p53 binds pizza
what he won and we can see that cast
line and the elements that we've
attached that D cast 9 protein are
binding they're very specific
specifically as specifically as p53 the
percent input here demonstrates the
yield of ship DNA attained by a specific
antibody
so with that be happy to take any
questions that concludes the
presentation one Thank You Jeremy for
that informative presentation we will
now start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar you have a question you'd like
to ask please do so now
let's click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation winner
I could question it into the box that
appears on the screen and click the send
button well answer as many of your
questions as we have time for so let's
get started our first question is how
much lentivirus should be used in an in
vivo injection so this is uh this
question probably references that that
last publication that we showed it's
difficult to say exactly how much you
usually lentivirus you always want to
determine a functional titer because you
know that d the titer that's cool
determined from these Alliance essays is
not always represented to the
representative of the functional titer
but in the next room with these 49
nanograms of p24 protein and one Michael
one of Michael that are locally injected
into the end of the brains of mice your
me how many off-target sites should be
considered for analysis so that's that's
a great question you can look at any
number of off target sites really
because the methods that we use to
predict off target sites are not
entirely comprehensive but if we do use
the methods that we have available to us
you at a minimum you want to take take a
look at the top ten predicted off target
sites for the guy turning that chair
that you're studying and that you're
performing your experiments with our
next question is how long should I wait
to assess the phenotype from the gene
knockout experiment okay that uh that
really depends on the format of the
CRISPR that you're using so plasmids
will require transcription and
translation in order to have an effect
in cell sometimes that can take as
little as six hours or as as much as 24
hours linty virus again requires the
same thing our our NP products arrive a
nuclear protein products are active
immediately upon to live
those effects and genotypic can be done
in as little as six hours after the use
of those buzzes so dependent upon the
format of the reagent you're using a
much sooner when using an RNP than when
using a plasma that our lunch virus then
germy it looks like we have time for one
more question what is the preferred
method of delivery for our NPS in neural
stem cell lines I think an be delivered
and with you know lipid based delivery
technologies that you might be familiar
with but but there's not quite as
efficient as electrical expiration based
delivery technologies we prefer to use
nuclear fiction here Sigma but really
any type of electroporation based
technology would be best for the
delivery of private nuclear proteins or
our impedes I would like to once again
thank Jeremy for his presentation I
would also like to thank Mel Corsica for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I'd like to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand replay route
June of 2018 you will receive an email
from laberd's letting you know when your
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again soon goodbye